so TIFF don't be angry oh oh you cut
your hair so today is it another day at
the house so we are about to head out
see our outer groceries head of
groceries we haven't gone grocery
shopping in like three weeks I think
yeah something like that
the last time we went to grocery
shopping we still had other groceries
from the previous times we packed
grocery shopped but now we've waited
long enough for us to be out of all
meats we have no more meat it's at one
point was filled to the brim full of
meats now it's all empty and we have
like other we have some tamales left but
this is like backup backup please have
some dumplings and some frozen stuff
like all that's meant for backup and
then all this is an effort backup so
we're not trying to touch the backup
food you know this stuff will last
forever just in case things were to get
where you want to rely on that stuff you
want to go grocery shopping for you to
know it's cuz they're about to get their
food so every time we're near the
scheduled time they're just like is it
coming in is it coming yet hurry up I'm
hungry
look at my so vocal you got away buddy
he's so cute like are you taking me to
every morning I want to make coffee I
like to play with the refrigerator door
cuz it reflects light oh yeah and then
he's going ham on this long thing oh
yeah going grocery shopping let's go
into the scary real world yeah has your
anxiety died down at all you know what
as heightened as it was essentially now
it's like flipped because now I'm kind
of starting getting nervous about the
world going back to normal
really
like what is it gonna be like like are
we just forever gonna be scared of
everything and like the procedures of
things are gonna be shifted forever like
there's always gonna be a 6-foot
distance but yeah but that's exactly the
type of anxiety that I feel like I'm
gonna have in the future like what a
stranger is near me am I gonna start
thinking like step away don't worry
you're not wearing a mask or I don't
know like obviously I'm exaggerating but
I feel like a lot of people are gonna be
like that where they're just gonna be
very very afraid of the real world and
how that things are gonna change in how
strangers are gonna be behaving because
just the last time I went grocery
shopping there were some people that
weren't wearing a mask and I'm like
internally judging them cuz I'm like how
dare you like how dare are you not
wearing it
so true yeah I just had an experience
the other day when something guy was
dropping off some food we ordered some
food some post mates and the guy dropped
off the wrong food he caught his own
mistake so about um so we have our nest
right and so we're always like all right
is the driver gone he's leaving okay
cool now we can come out it's safe for
us to grab our food and they just leave
it by our door and he did exactly that
but by the time I got out there he was
already walking back up he was like oh I
think I gave you the wrong order now I
was like okay so I waited for him and I
and in the back of my mind I was like oh
you should probably just go back inside
Casey and have him switch off the food
and then you know that probably did that
be the best way but I also felt socially
awkward to go oh you're gonna drop off
another bag and you're gonna come back
up this way I'll go back inside I just
felt weird for opening the door and
having to go back inside and I don't
know actually I felt weird so I decided
not to go back inside
I stayed at my door you walks back up
pawsley oh you could just leave the food
on the floor you know right there like a
safe distance away from me and then oh
you know but get it out bring also swept
up the food but you just held onto the
thing and I was like how you just drop
it down and you
like it but then he was like all like
looking at his phone and all that
concern that he was doing his job wrong
I don't think he heard me
so then I was like ah screw it I just I
just want this interaction to end so
then I grabbed the bag that was the
wrong bag and I gave tennety yeah yeah
out of his hand so we did an in-person
exchange and I felt totally weird by
that too so no oh my gosh you are and I
wasn't wearing a mask yeah but I helped
I held my breath I held my breath when I
was doing that and then I walked back
inside wash my hands and and I'll wash
like up to my elbow and stuff so I think
I did okay and I feel okay today I don't
know if we told you guys this part but
when we got the dining table the people
working on our neighbor's yard they
wanted some of the cardboard so then
they can use it for like their knees or
whatever as they're doing the
construction so they asked us like oh
can we have your cardboard where you're
done we're like yeah totally what he
asked us though he was wearing a mask
when he came up to us but then as we're
like trying to move the boxes from the
sidewalk or actually they were
technically on the street because the
delivery people it was like a pallet so
you couldn't put it on the sidewalk so
then Casey and I are like moving the
boxes one by one and they're pretty damn
heavy they're really heavy that's why
the guy he comes back that this time he
doesn't have a mask on and he was like
oh do you guys need help and I was like
no no it's okay thank you thank you so
much like we got it no worries but I
guess he felt like he had to help if he
was gonna get boxes from mrs. oh yeah it
was like an exchange in his mind they
may do something for you so then he
ended up even though it was just like no
no it's okay cuz I'm walking towards the
pallet and then he was closer than I was
so by that point I was like okay I'll
stop here then and then Casey was going
with with the dolly so then this man and
Casey were like really close to each
other no one's wearing a mask at this
point and I was just like okay thank you
okay
I it's really strange when when people
are doing something genuinely nice for
you or like they're trying to you know
do something right it ends up coming off
like it's as if it's something wrong to
do to polite yes what were your room
yeah and then I feel rude and then you
make them feel like they're rude and it
just doesn't help thing I know it's
weird
anyway it's written Cooper she shot me
alright just pulled up to the grocery
store and my second tip yeah is this
mint this this is for the chin or for
the nose yeah I'm like it really smushes
my nose into the thing doesn't feel very
comfortable could be like a little
pocket for your chin is it's more
comfortable I don't blame you because
when I first wore these masks when I got
them in Japan I initially wore them the
other way too like this and I used I was
thinking too that this is like you know
the seams and your clothes yeah so I
worried like this one time we're in Hong
Kong cuz I was like oh that looks
cleaner and so I was wearing it like
this the whole day but then at the end
of the day I had a line yeah but we just
got to the grocery store and it's just
so I feel like you know like superhero
heroes where you have to like suit up
yeah suit up I'm like you're trying to
put your mask on as you're trying to
hold getting it on the right way
good job proud of you know I've been a
superhero that wore my costume
this mask is technically a little too
loose for my face cuz I have I have
freaking small face all I do though is
pulled behind the ears and then kind of
like tightens a little bit but these
Messrs dope like I they only sell these
in Japan and these are really really
cool cuz it's like really soft and then
you can wash them up to six times so
these have been our go-to mess now that
we have to wear masks out in the world
and the public yeah we're talking about
blocking this experience like just for
our own memories and stuff because this
is like the world has changed
like dramatically where now everyone
inside the store has to wear masks
everyone has to be like at least six
feet apart they have stickers on the
ground to tell you where you can line up
so let's go see how this door eats then
I haven't been to the store since it's
been mandatory to her mess the last time
we came it was still like okay they're
not it was like the initial panic when
there was like so many people here there
was like a line around the block it was
crazy but we haven't been a whole lot of
places like in terms of vlogging we
haven't really done a whole lot of stuff
things been happening which I guess is
what we're supposed to be exact yeah but
oh yeah but we haven't recorded
ourselves out in public with mask song
and for memory sake they're doing it
today
[Music]
how do we get the bag with bag
all right so just finished grocery
shopping oh yeah I could take this off
yeah ah yeah we didn't vlog after we put
on the gloves because we realized like
if we're wearing the gloves to prevent
contamination then by touching the
camera and YouTube I was a sterile
processing technician so I went to
school to learn about contamination
decontamination sterilization honest
upright and then like proper practices
when you're taking off their PPE which
is in person - there's pretty personal
protective equipment PPE stands for and
so like I don't know like wearing the
gloves and wearing the mask like it like
gave me a flashback of working at the
hospital again where I'm like okay like
don't touch anything bunch of my face I
kept using my eye
to adjust my mat and then I caught you
touching your face with your mask and I
like no you're contaminating your mix it
was hard because I'm like and I start
trying to be doing the shoulder thing
but then my shoulder like my clothes
belong to the mask because it would just
drag it down further after I pushed it
up for us at the hospital we have to
assume everything we're touching has
blood on it and all this blood has like
HIV on it and like you have to you have
to assume that everything you're
touching that's contaminated is
contaminated with like the worst
possible thing so you have to constantly
be aware like don't like touch your body
don't touch your head like anywhere on
your head like and then when you remove
the gloves you have to remove it from
your wrist out and you have to like make
sure you're not contaminating anything
so I don't know like all of this I feel
like it's prepared me for this pandemic
right I'm glad that I'm with you while
we're going through all these minimal
yeah I mean I don't know now this kind
of makes me want to refresh like steam
sterilization and like the amount of
time you should be steaming something to
disinfect it or just and sanitize it
because those are two different things
you know what else is weird
what swear I've been having dreams
working at the hospital again and being
in the contamination room which is the
room where surgical instruments come
straight from from surgery so they're
all covered in blood and stuff that they
have to be washed like rinsed and get
like all the human stuff off of it yeah
and in that room is where we wear all
the PPD because then once it goes
through the washers and in the next room
it's where we assemble it everything in
that room should be clean so we don't
wear clothes for that room anyway in the
decontamination room I keep having
dreams that I'm working at the hospital
again I'm in that room
wearing my pee pee but for some reason
I'm not wearing shoes and I'm barefoot
and I'm just like oh this is so nasty
I'm like in this the nastiest room in
the whole friggin Hospital and I have
like I have no shoes on must mean
something
have you tried searching it one of the
jakey news articles uncovered recently
was that people are searching up their
drains more frequently and I'm just like
so grossed out and I'm not wearing shoes
there
maybe it's your Mexican heritage
speaking to you and like you know how
like raising kids you always got to have
Isaac with socks on or something can't
be barefoot in the house so you're gonna
get a cool yeah
and it's maybe it's maybe your Mexican
culture is in conflict with Chinese
culture because Chinese culture is those
a group she was off all the time
don't you guys worry slippers true I
don't know growing up you aren't really
like that into the whole station shoes
off so I'm just speaking in a generic I
noticed that there were some fans you
could just kind of tell if someone's
energy when they recognize even public
so they're like all too excited to be
out and about these days okay that's
like a very obvious reaction what ends
up happening is like someone gets really
really excited which is awesome because
I'm super excited to meet you guys too
and then like they take out the phone
and I guess they're double checking like
wait is this this person that's what I'm
assuming peridot and then cuz I think
bring out their phone and they're just
like oh and they're like speaking to
each other's and they're looking at me
and then they're just like this very
clear energy you know but you feel the
eyes and you feel the murmurs yeah so
then I was thinking in that moment I'm
like oh my gosh
this is this will be the first time like
the first fan interaction
things got really really crazy what's
the proper editor yeah so I'm like what
do I do
cuz I love hugging you guys when you
guys come up to us you know and I'm just
like thank you but then luckily that
ain't come up to us I'm saying luckily
because look like we avoided an awkward
situation but I don't know like whoa at
that bit like true when it was what
would you do if you met your favorite
celebrity guy who can just go hey man
big fan shake their hand give them a hug
selfie it up now it's like
I know I just feel something I can't
move like if I'm looking a box
I think because of my my the hospital
background in my head is like constantly
there I think that's kind of thank you
me out a little bit more I'm just like
don't
anything because and also there be
people that come into the hospital that
they have to have like they
where they have to be like in their room
pretty luncheon anyone I go they explode
having that background knowledge
the whole world of the next place room
now
all things come to an end eventually
that like residue
we all remember this era just like
people that went through the Depression
era and like till the end of their life
the
they hoarded food in there
they were free like women when
for that
[Music]
ketta leftovers from last night but it's
a responsible looking and lunch up on
that nothing goes to waste trying to not
waste any food this is our dairy from
last night
and it's our lunch for today what do you
have - looks like you're getting ready
for something very cool bit and kind
very nice very hip
James Cage white oh yeah yeah yeah I'm
putting on my face because I'm gonna be
joining Steve and Joe Joe and Steve on
their live stream oh nice yeah guys
gonna do on our live stream I have no
idea I have no expectations is this like
your first live stream since like all
the you know how like a lot of people
are doing live streams now lion
scrimmage that really popular think is
like especially like celebrity musicians
and stuff they can't do their concert so
they've done livestream constant
concerts is this your first live stream
since all the eggs
fu-uck we're doing makeup as a kid right
unless I'm talking to the camera I don't
know like third person I'm just like I
have no control over this you know what
I like about you doing your makeup
though is that you have like this slight
smile when you do your makeup and it's
like really pleasant to look at no I
like I like experimental doing your
makeup yeah just like this is normally a
dead faces like this but your Dead face
is a lot prettier than my Dead face but
then you go I'm like thank you very
slight you to get the cheekbones in when
I'm having a beautiful face I mean it so
sweet
I don't know these days and then I you
sitting on my makeup as often as I used
to before the world changed
you've been lazier to do it speaking of
which I've also been really lazy with
doing my hair my hair also just is too
long for me to even do in the first
place now why should cut my own hair I
think I hope you cut my hair here to
help me fill my hair film because I'm
just scared to cut your hair really
don't want you to blame me for the
catastrophe the inevitable catastrophe
will happen if I am the one doing your
hair true I mean I think it's a welcomed
inevitable catastrophe because I'm at
the point where like I kind of want to
just cut my own hair - that is and then
how you say that word inevitable
catastrophe why do you get used to you
why me
why am i why am i because you like to
use big words such as lackadaisical I'm
feeling lackadaisical these days that
doesn't really sound like a pretentious
big word that sounds like a made-up big
word really it's an essay - you were no
I remember that worth because of the
eighties you didn't miss much a lot of
torment okay you know but I was gonna
say you didn't miss out on much but this
just anxiety filled and dread of like
not doing good enough you know it's like
you label yourself with like I'm stupid
or something very fine I remember I got
a pretty decent x4 I remember this for I
do remember thinking like like you know
they tell you like the ranges like
good those are cool I did good tight
yeah is it true I never really used my
SAT I got I gotta use my SAT scores to
get into my first University and then I
pretty much flunked out of that
University and went to a private school
like that buddy call it a tech school
with technical sense that I want to yeah
earlier but all that stuff I know you
had the nurse stuff yeah it was a I
think was six months and at sex school I
don't remember I'm gonna try cutting my
hair not a manscaped
brandy but uh this is a man scape and
got some JK news I'm bringing it to get
youse
[Music]
[Music]
all right I think I call it quits this
is as good as it's gonna get before I
really really do some damage I think
that bald spot right there I can't tell
if I'm either improvement on handsome
universe it was an A for effort
and I do so upon some further inspection
I think I hacked my hair to death so
with the hat on I don't think it's too
bad on this sides a lot more training I
got to brave on this side oh boy my tip
is done with her live stream she'll let
me know how I did on the back side and
if anything if it's really that bad
we'll find out if and you know no not
the edges a little bit for me I was
really wanting a haircut because it was
starting to tickle my ears and I was
starting like tickle my face and the
back of my neck now I'm starting to
regret cutting my hair altogether
I mean if we have another few more weeks
of quarantine and justice at all even
out by the time cork is worth the try
all right so if TIFF is taking a break
from her nap podcast I am so used to
saying podcast with you that it's it's a
podcast forever now live stream yeah
okay well oh sweet doesn't happen
forever but uh so tip don't be angry
Oh
you cut your hair why am i angry what
would I be angry
it's your thoughts did you do this or
who did it I tried I did it myself
you did it yourself yeah you're gonna
have Isaac help you you don't want to do
it you owe me to hell vectors yes I
don't know if but I think you would have
a better time help getting it to look
better to my credit though I achieved
what I wanted to do which was to get the
tickle unis out of the sides of my neck
in the side of my head the word that
would quote unquote anger me is where
did you do this oh I did it outside in
the backyard so all my hairs are out
there check out the back though this is
where the real work happened the real
magic happens back here I didn't see
what what anyway I still haven't seen it
though I don't know I'll have to play
the video back
I know oh my goodness this is crazy Oh
sniff oh my goodness you're so funny I
will help sweet okay you're being funny
do you think that oh I say goodbye what
what happened he's logging this too by
the way what's up everybody
oh wait what do you guys think oh yeah
oh you can't help them me wearing a head
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know why it's right here on both
sides like right there my strip model
drawback sorry Steve I achieved what I
wanted to do with the haircut
what's up Stedman I know good here your
hair is long it's this is the log that
has ever been in my life
Steve's jelly
[Music]